[Applaudissements]
et il y a déviance déviance du débat
parlementaire vous n’expliquez pas votre
amendement vous profitez de la tribune
pour faire des effets tribunes parce que
vous savez qu'on vous regarde et
effectivement les gens nous regardent
[Applaudissements]
et faut leur dire la vérité aux gens
ils prennent pas deux ans à cause de la
réforme
ils prennent selon toujours le mécanisme
que vous connaissez bien des délais
supplémentaires liés effectivement faut
le reconnaître et nous assumons nos
responsabilités un décalage d'âge que
l'on préconise est lié à l'augmentation
de la durée 43 ans qui a fait
l'augmentation de la durée c'est pas 43
ans plus deux ans les gens ont déjà pris
la plupart du temps ils ont pris le
délai supplémentaire
assumez-le parce que c'était facile
excusez-moi c'était facile
merci oui oui
mille excuses mille excuses
mais faut assumer tu le rapporteur
de prendre des réformes qui concernent
les suivants et les réformes touraines
elles commencent seulement à s'appliquer
et elle va faire ses effets-là mais
dites-le dans les manifestations si vous
travaillez plus longtemps c'est à cause
de nous quand même et pas forcément à
cause d'eux
donc si vous voulez si vous voulez jouer
sur ce terrain là nous sommes preneurs
mais faut dire l'ensemble des
thématiques les effets positifs et les
effets négatifs alors volontiers vous
voyez à travers le corps une
justification le Conseil d'orientation
des retraites il y a des gens qui nous
écoutent vous voyez des significations
simplement vous oubliez de dire que tous
les scénarios même les plus optimistes
conduisent à une dégradation des contes
de retraite avec une retraite plus
faible des retraités baisse baisse du
pouvoir
relativement au salaire moyen baisse du
pouvoir des retraités
85% à l'horizon 2030 2040 contre 103%
dites-le à vos amis que vous êtes
favorables à une baisse de leur niveau
de vie aux retraités ce sera sans dire
la vérité
et bien face à cela
face à cela face à cela nous sommes
responsables et nous prenons les
décisions qu'il faut parce que nous ne
voulons pas nous que nos enfants à
travailler jusque 65 ans nous ne voulons
pas nous que nos enfants et à travailler
plus de 43 ans 45 46 ans parce que c'est
ça l'équivalent d'une absence de prise
de responsabilité les suivants vont
hériter une dégradation de notre système
et il se la réforme sera encore plus
brutale plus en retard d'apprendre les
décisions plus la réforme est brutale
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
sommes attentifs et je vous invite mes
chers collègues vous qui êtes sensibles
à la prise en compte des mers de famille
d'attendre les articles qui vont
effectivement faire que nous prenons des
mesures tout à fait significatives pour
les maires de famille car nous aussi
nous en parlons pas nous faisons des
propositions
merci merci monsieur le rapporteur
madame Lubin c'est une réaction de
Madame Lubin
alors puisqu'on commence à se parler
puisqu'on commence à se parler
franchement
ah vous étiez impatient alors on va
revenir en arrière on va revenir en
arrière qui sait qui a permis aux
ouvriers de ce pays qui jusqu'en 1981
commençait à travailler à 14 ans qui
finissait à 75 mais ouais c'est pas si
vieux que ça qui finissait à 65 et qui
mourait avant d'avoir tout juste après
avoir profité de quelques mois de
carrière qui c'est qui est revenu en
arrière immédiatement qui sait qu'un 93
à placer le calcul sur les 25 meilleures
années pour faire baisser le niveau des
retraites qui c'est qui en 2010 s'est
passé de 2003 ou 2010 je sais plus qui
est passé et passé de 60 à 62 ans et
malgré tout et malgré tout il a fallu
faire encore des réformes la preuve que
celle que vous aviez faite elles étaient
mauvaises pour les salariés et mauvaise
pour le système pour le régime de
retraite et pour son équilibre c'est ça
la réalité et la réforme Touraine j'ai
eu l'occasion de le dire hier oui elle a
mis à 43 exactement
mais elle a continué à permettre à des
gens qui commençaient à travailler avant
20 ans de partir à 62 et c'est à ça que
vous allez toucher aujourd'hui je vous
ai écouté jusqu'au bout chers collègues
et c'est à ça que vous allez toucher
aujourd'hui alors s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît moi ce que je sais quand je
regarde 40 ans en arrière 40 ans c'est
quand j'ai commencé à m'intéresser à la
politique
ce que je sais c'est que s'il n'y avait
jamais eu de gauche au pouvoir les
ouvriers travailleraient toujours
jusqu'à 65 ans voire même pourquoi pour
pourquoi pas un peu plus mais si ça
serait ça la réalité et quand vous nous
dites que vous ne voulez pas que vos
enfants travaillent
vous inquiétez pas
vous suite au prochain numéro merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]